we made it to where it was it was cool
and I feel like it got this identity
back as far as for a sec and then the
identity became all the drama man yeah
how do you guys prevent that same [__]
from happening
with your well [__] there's a lot of
drama I say we're not doing a good job
cause your [__] happened I mean but you
know
initially when drama happens it's it's
not on us you know what I'm saying that
it's not our job to post clips and post
the videos and go hard with it like
we're not in control of that so if drama
happens and if you putting it out that
has nothing to do with us you know I'm
saying it can stay internally it can
stay in-house but if you choose to put
it out it has a platform as a company
that's on you you know what I'm saying
we didn't ask nobody to do that we don't
control the clip channel the main
channel the Instagram we're not for sure
any of that [__] so who's really
controlling the narrative you know what
I'm saying like who's controlling what's
going on and what you guys see as far as
the drama and that really was like no on
camera drama like our pod at the end of
the day has never beefed or argued not
one [__] time you know I'm saying in
the other part that left uh which was
disconnected they've never had any drama
at all either so all that other [__] was
just [__] that didn't have anything to
do with us and we'll just speak on it
you know what I'm saying so those clips
will arrive from that [__] you know what
I'm saying and videos are right from
that [__] but still like we wasn't in
control of putting that out so we y'all
written and the people really can't
blame us for that [__] so you know what
I'm saying and two is you you can't win
for lose because if you don't speak
about it oh you're scared you ain't
speaking about it or you're a PC and
when you do speak about it oh you're a
messy you shouldn't do that so it's like
people don't know what they want well I
think like I said that too when I was
with Adam I said like wouldn't you
rather
have your your boys get the the views
that come with reacting to some of this
[__] because otherwise
a bunch of other YouTube channels are
going to talk about it whether it's
academics or milk 7-4 or whoever the
[__] like people are going to make their
reactions and you guys have your own
platforms and you guys are kind of the
source it's like wouldn't
I would rather but what makes it any
different don't no jumper do it yeah for
sure yeah but within their cooling they
do it's a problem you know what I'm
saying like what do we're learning we're
literally watching what you guys are
doing
you feel me you've given us the
blueprint we're designing what we're
doing and adding our own spin to it
around that right so it's like look you
can't say well you guys are doing this
and reacting to this but y'all doing the
same [__] too it may be a rapper you
feel me who don't appreciate that it may
be somebody else but we're literally
doing the same exact thing the people
and like I say all the time we don't sit
there and just wake up in the morning oh
we about to just be messy and do this no
the fans literally will sit there and
spam [__] in the chat like talk about
this talk about this and be like all
right y'all want to talk about this
we're here now right and then it's like
it just blows over and then you know I
prime example you know he said uh you
know drama doesn't equal money and you
know sometimes it doesn't but also in
this Kelpie situation I'm gonna keep
bringing it up like we that was in-house
nobody didn't have to know about that
nobody didn't have to know about the
fight nobody had to see that clip nobody
didn't have to do none of that [__]
right you guys chose to put that out you
know why because that [__] equals
dollars you feel me it equals attention
equals because they were like sitting on
that for a while right sitting on that
you know what I'm saying but you got
legal reasons too but you but if if
there were no legal reasons that [__]
would have been put out immediately you
know what I'm saying so that again
that's not on us we didn't do that right
we're not in control of that you know
what I'm saying so
now it's becoming Financial this doesn't
equal dollars and that show wasn't kind
of like well this is the world that you
kind of consciously created yeah like
you know what I'm saying you curated
this [__] I didn't we don't I didn't
come there to do that I came here to
laugh but no but when you put people in
certain situations it's kind of like you
know Love and Hip Hop or something like
that if you know probably people got
problems with each other and you're
curating to put them in the same room of
course Something's Gonna blow up so even
when Kelpie came over here Kelpie had
his situation with Almighty and sharp it
didn't leave on a good note no it was it
was already drama the first time yeah
yeah you get invited back to sit next to
this
so why are we inviting this young man
back yeah why did he come it didn't make
no sense that didn't even make any sense
you know but it does it did make sense
because it makes dollars and sense you
know what I'm saying we come back
because he's viral so let's go viral
again young man you know what I mean now
we're gonna go super viral because we
can't even bring out the whole interview
so we just gonna put out the fight [__]
it foreign so I mean hey I'm but [__]
you know it's Financial Times over there
I mean we had to get out of there anyway
you feel me because I don't like I said
I didn't want to be a burden to anybody
because he wasn't making money on our
show our show was you know wasn't making
money and that's what people was like I
don't like that narrative too the show's
not making money we all in YouTube we
all know what's going on yeah per se yes
the long form content may not make that
much money but once you chop it down a
million times put on the clips service
it to to Facebook service it to
Instagram real service at The Tick Tock
and you do all this stuff like that yeah
then it's gonna really be something but
the fact that it's not making any money
that ain't true at all but even if it if
even if it you know it wasn't and it was
just breaking even you know what I'm
saying we're we're still bringing a ton
of subscribers so we're bringing it
we're bringing yeah we're bringing
people to the channel so if you you're
here they're living on the channel so if
you watch it at the end of the day and
you have work and it's only hour or two
you got six more hours to go guess what
you got to do you're gonna live on the
channel and still watch other views so
it's you can't really determine on how
much money that we were making the
channel in this entirety